so hi there we're here back at devoxx
exciting conference so far lots of
content I have with me the chrome guys
so I have Joe I have Pascua and these
guys have been here talking about chrome
apps and I'll start with you Joe
and tell us what Chrome apps are even
yeah differ from any real apps there so
they're relatively new which we
officially launched them back in
September we've been developing them for
a couple of years now essentially chrome
apps are a way to use html5 to develop
real native feeling applications
applications that look and feel like
native ones they run outside the browser
they work offline by default they work
on desktop as well as mobile so it's
it's a great way for developers to build
real native experiences so a lot of
things you covered here briefly here you
want to cover the offline part what does
it really mean to be offline yeah sure
so you know we're all familiar with
building web applications right so you
use html5 you build your web application
it's online so when you build a chrome
app you build it the same way html5
JavaScript CSS but all the resources are
packaged up at locally into an
application it's local on your machine
like an installed app is and you can run
the app when you're not connected or
when you have a connection that's not so
good and it just behaves normally great
yeah so that's that's that's really
obviously very important another thing
is you can access computer the laptop or
the machines resources as in the USB
port or the file system and stuff like
that so you know that brings up the
ability to build whole new range of
applications yes
typically a web app could not yeah sure
so I mean we leverage html5 wherever
possible
but when html5 does not provide a
certain feature we have chrome app API
is that that fill in for things like
file access and USB and Bluetooth and
sockets okay so one of the reasons I
have Francois here with us also is that
Francois has been doing some of that
which is integrating with some of the
hardware available on machines do you
want to tell us more about what you're
doing here at devoxx
one guy actually in google named luis
built an awesome library on javascript
to be able to communicate with those USB
NFC reader okay what we've done is we've
been the chrome app which helps with
registration and the response that
everybody has here and you can scan it
and write to it directly from a chrome
app only with web technologies it's used
here for registration for you know
delivering the wristbands checking
what's on those wristbands which is used
throughout the conference and we use
those on Chromebooks but that could be
on any machine that's running foam which
kind of brings me to the question of how
are these packaged and delivered I mean
those Chrome apps yeah so basically
there it depends also on desktop
machines they're packaged up as zip
files and they're stored in the Chrome
Web Store and so you go to the Chrome
Web Store you download and install the
application and it's the same as you
download an app from any other app store
on mobile we use the Cordova library to
package up applications as native apps
so they're basically native apps that
host your web code and they get packaged
as a native app for that platform so for
Google they go in the Play Store for iOS
they go in the Apple App Store so
Dominion with its desktop or mobile
that's how they get delivered so how
real are chrome apps today on mobile how
far along a week well it's really early
days right now we have a team of people
in Canada and Waterloo that are working
on contributing to the Cordova effort
we've got you know a good set of the
core API is ported over now we think
that probably by early 2014 we should be
in good shape for people to start
building real apps great so how would
somebody go about building an app
pushing it out and making it known so
there's a store for that people find out
about those well I mean to build it it's
really easy you can go to our website
it's developer.chrome.com/apps that's
where all the information about the API
is is stored if you want to go to github
we have a github repo at github comm
slash Google Chrome
then there's a Chrome App samples repo
in there shows all the samples so those
are probably the places I would start to
to learn how to build these great
francois how hard was it to actually
build this once the library was
available and library is done so easy
great and we are hoping to make this
library open great yeah I think there's
a it's interesting to be able NFC is
obviously not built in every machine but
certainly devices like like this one has
it and it'd be great to be able to tap
into the that kind of resources any
final words on we're good next what you
expect from you know this technology
going forward right we're you know we're
we're building to api's all the time
we've already got a lot of great apps in
the Chrome Web Store there's some great
partners have built so we're continuing
to see some really good uptake in the
platform among partners you know we're
looking really forward to getting these
things out on mobile we're looking
forward to be people building mobile
apps so I I'm I think that it's it's
early days it's just beginning and I'm
really excited to see where it goes well
great I think I heard good things about
your session certainly here the box and
people can catch it soon then absolutely
on parlays if I can had something you
should so Chrome EPR great but my hope
is that they will be destroyed in a
matter of years so that the web can yeah
I'm actually nuts right so you're saying
HTML plus plus five plus whatever it
would be great to have a lot is a
standard it would be great to see a lot
this stuff get standardized over time
okay yeah great but you need to start
somewhere somewhere exactly right Chrome
apps yeah check it out thank you